world cup 2014 is in effect it's
happening oh it's so what am I don't
watch soccer until the world cup comes
around then I watch a lot well you got a
good dose of soccer this time around
yeah football UK and Ireland Europe sup
other places in the world except for
America sure we used to call it soccer
an island I don't know what people who
used to be okay in England till like the
ladies as well people got over sense of
real it was I was basically when
American football start getting
broadcast in the UK the people started a
funny about football soccer thing like
no no this is our football it was funny
Arnez gated football so were you
stopping to sports anyway we called it
soccer anyway regardless USA are playing
Germany in a big old game thanks to
Bradley's little mess up some bad
defending and Cristiano Ronaldo
realizing that he was Cristiano Ronaldo
in the last like hey maybe I should show
up 95 within its 94 minutes late to the
game yeah but uh I'm here guess what's
up spoiling the u.s. at automatic
advancing so thursday morning it's all
on the line against germany yikes so
what better way to figure out who's
gonna win that game than by having Eric
Taylor and Marco Martinez step into the
shoes of USA and germany hey you guys
should probably swap sides right there
are you playing as Germany I'm playing
as the United States he's famous America
it's fine just get on to the next screen
just hit just always got his captain in
marriage got captain america on Marco
we're gonna trade her to your Mexican
side the favor yeah for the sake of this
we're just going to say he's supporting
mexico only but i know he's got a he's
got split allegiances at boys we're
gonna talk to you at halftime and but
for the moment I want the two of you to
concentrate on your game and myself and
Chris are gonna do our best Univision /
ESPN commentary over this so best of
luck and also give any comments in the
chat I got my laptop back please send
them over as well great see Josie out
there with his bionic leg they recently
put in using
zilean monkey femurs it's early chance
here for close-up trying to become the
leading scorer world cup history exactly
well you you really know you're at your
new knowledge I've used my two facts up
and it's all downhill from here Jozy
Altidore is broadly who had a bad game
against Ghana in the first game and
there had a good first half against the
Portuguese but I had proved to a little
bit clumsy at the end of that game azle
boys'll miroslav I fell off the end and
it's gonna be as tough as I miss say his
eyes are offside his eyes are upside
miroslav oh so his eyes are offside I
know also that's not his first name I
don't even understand what that means
he's got big eyes Oh Bradley Roby the
top dairy co-op Dempsey hey wolf safeway
clear it out Johnson Jones Johnson
working it outside the old box situation
and it's a sloppy pass pool is gonna
take that one we gotta Germany on the
counter-attack here Oh closer closer
fight for it he's gonna be pick Gonzalez
closer than close that Gonzalez yeah
that's not of a German name no that's a
different because a United States yeah
okay he's a stator Johnson had to wing
to Bradley Oh looking for that across
the middle ball and it's just right
there for toby jones 2 and alexi lalas
to sweep up hahaha I never heard of
Alexi Lalas I moved here oh yeah also
steve mcmanaman is a pundit on the SBA
and had a [ __ ] that album I don't
even know is that is that if he's he
related to eric wynalda sure who's gonna
throw a choice I yo big save by Jimmy
how I bastian schweinsteiger messes up
how can you not say schweinsteiger like
free time looks so fun Feinstein Meltzer
kevin-prince that's how kevin-prince
boateng that's his brother the one who
didn't decide to play for gob Ebola Tang
close again into traffic yeah boys this
is that you're already talking to each
other getting a little bit nervy here
Eric Tanner's leaning in look at this
he's worried
the whole situation Tim the beard Howard
has it covered though Tim the beard he's
just like Jersey beard face that's it
apparently he's also got Tourette's I
did hear it I didn't read it yeah there
you go energetic fellow which helps when
you screaming at defenders all day
actually it's probably pretty good oh
that was a change ball surely all that
one but your balls bored I want
advantage not gonna call it and did look
around in the box is that guy music dude
one two three and twitch asks do to have
feigning injuries in this game painting
injury does feigning injury painting in
dairies unfortunately they don't they
don't think they've ever had that in a
game they had intentional foul and I
think it was FIFA 98 and but I don't
think they've ever had dive baby
injuries I feel like you'd meet you
getting into this like mutant league
mutant league a ball territory of like
rye breath like how do you it's like
I've done a dice roll to see if it works
like you have to build in some kind of
chances I'm later good work hard have it
red card was a game where you basically
got points for getting people sent off
as well oh here we go see this is an
obvious you've got to number one
commentators yeah I'll be the color guy
you'll be the color guy I'll be the
color commentator already that you be
the final crushing the US easy to move
it around to the back pressing up the
middle now and they're looking for a
through ball under Dempsey fantasy I'm
gonna be the color commentator also
comes in with questions from the chat
yeah that works and also I want to let
the people know at home that this is not
the world cup video game this is the f
rose above you laughing at all
you're really good at this and this is
the free upgrade pack for the next year
or current gen version so this is for
this is the ps4 we're playing on as to
this in the xbox one version there's a
free download pack and they have this
friendly mode and there's also daily
challenges based on what happens in the
game is this the unless haha suckers who
bought the world cup game mode we're
giving you that stuff basically for free
etha is that what I'm hearing there's
definitely like not as many modes in
this as there will be in the fully ready
charities this is there we're sorry we
didn't get ran to making a next-gen
world cup game okay uh sir surely
offsides there Jozy Altidore taking
shots from outside the box like some
sort of desperate [ __ ] come on Eric
Tanner you're better than this wait
who's which one's the Eric Taylor's the
United retailers united states quite
America over the top shipping it up hit
them fancy he shoots with his left he
shoots with his right eye people get it
definitely makes drugs but look scheisse
no or maybe you've got all the chance
down yeah he doesn't think the fulham
anymore though so I can't really use
anymore it's been a lot of possession by
the US and a lot of pressure up front
after a few quick counter strokes from
the German side know from that US has
been knocking on the door dear late in
this first half question from Sinead O
who's going to win the World Cup will
two teams be in the final sorry said
which two teams table me is a file
pretty sure two teams will be makalah
ahead and say yes who do you think Chris
Altidore mmm but do I think based on
first round play yeah I netherlands
brazil that that is not that seem pretty
like from pretty strong team I think
that can't happen I might not be able to
have I think they will meet in the
quarterfinals they'll they meet Anna for
that yeah I don't have the full bracket
in mind but uh I don't know Germany
that's pretty strong alright beans as
well Ian poms and a squirrel's first
half here yeah that's that let's talk to
both managers for a second and can we
talk Eric Taylor are we on Mario
Martinez I think you guys are on let's
have a quick chat What's it feel like to
be on a live
in for a soccer video game and be in a
scoreless draw at halftime miles go
ahead it's a dream come true that's
amazing I'm gonna win that's it you're
gonna break American hearts yeah for no
reason over internet fame yeah that's
the kind of taciturn attitude that's
given Martinez great success as the
German door technical director Taylor
how did you get out the door back on the
pitch considering he pulled a hamstring
two weeks ago uh family there roids I
was about to include Landon Donovan but
but we we went against that because he's
doing a great job in those commercials
so fair enough all right back to the
game boys that's eating second half what
are the keys here Danny for Germany if
they want to punch it in and avoid utter
embarrassment on the international spy a
drawing for using to the US I think yet
what a Germany have to do here of course
Germany if they draw this game I think
our oh no boats if draw will put both
these teams through indeed there was
just type of collusion by many as Jurgen
Klinsmann and the technical director of
the German side are the silly way back
yeah and may or may not be related by
blood I guess we'll see if somebody
scores late into the second half then
all gloves are off well would definitely
help is if both teams went into ultra
attack right now ultra attack here is
Johnson pressing it down the side
waiting for a seem to catch up trying to
get a better and badminton a shot in the
middle and amazingly both America and
Germany have opted to go for ultra
attack Wow it's as if both our system
sensing the desperations in their squad
and utterly unaware of the realities of
world cup qualification and this game
support EA game faces Oh Dino oxer oh
he's got Demps or Bradley in the middle
bc thanks for getting me trophy brah
haha appreciate it that's what we're in
it for folks I'm not sure I think it the
old versions are gay okay they're skena
poor Beasley Beasley Univision
commentary see Danny do your I don't
know any Spanish you do it Oh
los Estados me dos Manos y el defensor
lomonaco a lemon but they say no oh poor
ball wrong wrong option there my friend
squeaky bum time 60 minutes to go or no
one's really going to help these teams
here danny is taking that ball bringing
it down the field and just getting it by
the keeper for a goal is what they are
really trying to strive to do here I
think you know for the German see right
now this key in this end of the field
yeah prevent that ball from going into
the gold pass the peeper kill screen
asks what is the point of the map its
bottom of the script it's like your
radar it's good for like doing like
really ridiculous like long balls oh not
in front of the entire German squad
let's see if he can finish
miroslav closer they're achieving the
highest goal scorer in the world cup
finals regular cyst I thought what was
on the assist maybe was just it i don't
know i wasn't watching i'm the i'm the
Cockney I'm the company color
commentator who's actually a bit wasted
so I don't read I was going on Vinnie
Jones that's pretty jokes would be
really good what what these Americans
need to do is [ __ ] hit those Germans
right we've gotta hit real hard Oh
penalty le gros so that's a penalty I
don't knows the referee they've
obviously paid him off those stinking
Germans liking that always offsides his
offsides also boy outside terrible
touched by the defender Gonzalez but man
is to get on top of it closer trying to
claim that throne and that he's
currently sharing with over on aldo from
up brazil is it going to be an outside
shot terrible percentage here he's taken
to the baseline travel across the back
in front no Rob Rob old you could you
can see the despair in a manager there a
tailor's face can't believe this is
happening these Americans need to pull
the [ __ ] finger out right you just
get done this is war war but it's
actually for a football I don't know
spanish for the prism say we watch a
little disc you know borel ammonia or if
we great to divert news you have a team
out Chelsea out the doors got to use his
bionic leg there get to pull up the
pitch oh my goodness terrible defense
por los alemanes sigue sigue sigue
Johnson Oh
did not the lady where does yellow or
Jones Oh je je je it's quickie bunch on
seven minutes left in the game or to
close again Sebastian oi there no
problem for him you can catch American
balls all day long Oh desperation see
it's just knocking on the door so hard
but no one's answer and here we go Josie
Katie got the ball except where does
yellow that's worse that Bradley's
against Portugal what were you doing
Tyler I draw with a poop out these teams
through did he Jones would have scored
that Josie Josie Josie Seager Josie no
put it in here we go Oh incredible
amount of chances for the American side
there and they just couldn't put it in
one wonders if this is the time when we
really see one minute injury time how
far just not on the national scene how
far they still have yet to go Oh
desperate long ball what is this ball
and that'll do it and also is broken
himself oh he's gonna miss the finals
what's happened to him what's the injury
dislocated shoulder ouch ow you yeah
lets up in in stoppage time well at
least you still got her legs to stand on
it automatically does that oh really
yeah when you get hurt Oh what and then
it does that little thing there we go
that's it American is my gosh Marco
Martinez as an American how does it feel
like to put out the Beast metal how does
it feel hashtag Beast medals the photos
put out tomorrow it was amazing I knew
my team was gonna do that from the
beginning I was asked to put my hand
behind my back made to give him a
handicap that I didn't I played a
hundred percent i won
one that's let us see the stats real
quick they're ok I want something look
at the stats is this you shot stats oh
that's cutting it what is that a
seven-shot 7 on target mmm that's pretty
good it's consistent at it it's in
German efficiency right there if you
rate a hundred percent shot accuracy
good game Oh snubbing just missed it the
sports blogs are gonna be all Twitter
about that how come I Tina is where at
Eric Taylor thank you very much thanks
also for not biting each other oh yeah
oh they're always with the kiss each
other there yeah the bite kiss it's a
complicated expression of emotion I
don't know about you but I'm spending
nine o'clock on thursday morning in kate
o'brien's to watch the watch the game
really you should come along I will go
to they're gonna go we're gonna go not
go to our meetings and watch watch
sports and drink beer in the morning
it's the American